some dude that was [ __ ] sleeping with
a fox if you get a fox from the [ __ ]
woods
to [ __ ] wear a harness and this
[ __ ] is walking a fox to the
starbucks i mean it's a fox
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god
with me george lopez
sport you know george is oh i'm sure
he's around here somewhere
what's his name george george lopez
oh my god omg omg hi
oh my god
you probably know me better than anybody
over the last
20 plus years three years yeah
when i'm not here i never talk that much
in a row
no like we we talked for 40 minutes
yeah or or even 10 minutes or 15
and you're being you know remotely
amusing or whatever anybody thinks but
i'm being honest 100 honest
to say the least and i've never been
allowed to be honest even in the
beginning you don't know that
when you're when you're more successful
they're going to ask you to be less of
you
and more like somebody they want or at
least that's what it was for me
but i no i'm not sure i
you know i don't know well i gotta i
play yeah i don't know what to say
i mean i think i i learned a lot in the
first show
but also i had good people looking after
me
that allowed me not to be crazy because
you know roseanne goes crazy or
brad butler they go crazy comedians go
crazy and
andrew dice clay had the v whatever the
guy bless his house that was a pretty
good show yeah great show and he
he called les moonves on the weekend to
complain about bruce and the
unless moonbeds canceled the show and
that show was doing well
because it's not worth the headache oh
man
but you know television has been on a
long long time
and when you look at the characters or
people who have survived
a lot of them maybe weren't even very on
very long yeah
but they make more of an impact on you
than some
show that maybe was on multiple times as
long as the show that you liked
but in um
in our culture pets or things
aren't i think a little bit more now but
aren't revered as
friends or emotional uh
uh pets or something to help you get
through
emotional support oh yeah yeah and
with lisa she helped me to um
become somebody who ended up rescuing
pets which i thought i never would be
like
you know when they bark i go crazy but
you know dog barks but also
it's i wouldn't say it's made me
different
i mean i really early on i thought about
letting them all go
one night just opening the door but
and i can't say that they appreciate it
more because they know that maybe
they're going to get the needle but
there's just something inside of me that
that she turned on in me that
makes me save dogs lives not cats [ __ ]
them
in mexico they're you they see you
walking in a bar with a cat they'll
[ __ ] throw you out
you don't walk in from up with a putter
for amsterdam where by like my tail with
four lights and one light smell like
pillow they'd be like come on here
the cats are the devil in mexico oh my
gosh
i can't [ __ ] well at least our so our
drivers who drive their trucks in the
middle of the night
all those guys
17 000 pounds of cocaine in the front
tire
they don't give a [ __ ] about cats el
chapo you know
i'm sure his mom left them right there
with a light on by himself
right right key kid all right so yes so
so lisa arturo
is is incredibly passionate big love
wrestling pets
and she can't wait to talk to her that
is her um
lot enlightenment i heard lauren walk
say that one time
oh no i didn't but if anybody remember
everything i was thinking
i do remember everything it is well
because i had nothing to look at i made
words my friends
that's uh i think something that people
know i learned about you is that you
never forget a thing like that i think
not a lyric
not even kicking me in my cool in your
ass as a 13 year old just trying to get
out have an adventure you kicked me in
my [ __ ]
one of the funniest things ever oh man
it hurts my hurts me just to think about
that when i had my colonoscopy i said
going to see there's any ulterior damage
from early on in life
i just had one of those arterial damage
uh how was your colonoscopy by the way
it was fantastic
it was you weren't around like i was
when you had to drink like 13 gallons of
sea water from right there the santa
monica pier
let me tell you how bad it was like this
stuff isn't that bad anymore it might be
a pill
when i was 45 or 40 let's say that was
probably
um 2001 i had my first colonoscopy
and they made me drink six
big ass bottles of stuff that tastes
like
water from the sea it was horrible
tasting you couldn't get it and the guy
says
the guy says i'm giving you
uh i think there may be four bottles and
he dropped him off at 3 p.m and he says
i'm gonna come back at nine
and when he came back at nine i think i
had drank maybe
one and had opened the other one and he
stood there
because by midnight i had to be done you
know watching new year and it was
the worst so now you can you know
hey take a couple of [ __ ]
alka-seltzers yeah seriously
it was not a problem for me i i started
the night before the hardest thing is
not eating
but i uh i threw down for a few minutes
or a few hours and then
i slept great woke up did the same thing
my wife's doing it right now
i don't want to see what's going to come
out of that thank god they don't save
any of that and show you
well you know man what do you think
it's going to be horrific for me tonight
because she's going to be not
not happy and i'm going to be if she
starts dribbling a basketball take off
that leg kick is coming up all right
beautiful let's uh all right that's
let's get to the news then let's start
off with the news well here's our first
one from times now news.com
some of these high end things what's the
worst
man married same woman four times
divorces her thrice in 37 days to get
extended pay leave
that's a lazy [ __ ] he's a
taiwanese man
married to the same woman four times a
divorce or thrice to get extended uh
unbelievable
um wait a minute tell me again he was he
was
married he marries the same woman four
times and divorces her three times
in 37 days to get extended pay leave
so he's kind of getting around the whole
deal so
so mary the same one four times what is
this how stupid is this dude is it
career tom
uh say what are you out there in
gardenia
he said when he requested for benkley
the bank approved an eight day leave for
the first
marriage he got married on april 6 last
year and once his marriage
leave was over he divorced his wife and
married her again the next day
to ask for another paid leave which he
felt was entitled to by law
he repeated this until he married four
times in divorce three times this way he
managed to apply
leaves for four marriages for a total of
32 days
what's his name lee say yes
uh yeah hey taiwanese man yeah same
thing
that's across the board miscellaneous
latino miscellaneous but however things
didn't go as planned
uh the bank figured out what he was
trying to do and refused to grant him
extra paid leave
the bank uh granted him paid leave for
only
for eight days for the first marriage so
he did all this for nothing
and think about that dude man come on
that's trying to pull the scam
on a place that he works at marries the
same woman
three times trying to just get what a
benefit
yeah he's trying to get uh trying to get
24 more days out of the deal
of of vacation paid leave how
how cheesy is that when you get caught
for that oh man that's that's rough
that is a cheap but but is i went along
with it
that's another one that's five they
probably both have query right there
below
that's probably like the crying game you
need to just change clothes
quad nose down below don't know a guy a
couple kids go down there
you know he'll wear the wig one week and
he's like oh that's another lady i met
after the tsunami yeah that kind of
stuff is like so embarrassing when you
get caught like being that cheesy
because it could have worked but i mean
you know there's a lot of people that
still
in between the margins but not where you
bring the same person maybe changes the
car or her top
you know this is like you're trying to
steal money for 24 days
yeah that's exactly what it is just
stealing right yeah pretty much you're
kind of setting yourself up
and i wonder what his wife looked like
they were like you're married here for
the fourth time hello
well when was this what year did this
happen just right now this was this year
yeah
yeah he uh yes it was
april of april of last year what about
somebody mail order like i watch youtube
i mean you found your bride but do you
know anybody that's ever
sent away for a woman and got one that
shows up at the airport
with like two good teeth and all the
rest of them are black
no but uh you know with just nasty feet
and
i want have you ever seen have you ever
seen anybody who's had a uh
on a tv or anything mail order bread
i've never seen anything
i just know of the stories when i was
working i worked with a woman who was
taiwanese beautiful girl and she was
dating a police officer
that was on the on the force allegedly
lapd
and she was so mean to that guy that he
would cry
at a party oh my god and he was an lapd
officer and he was like
kind of like i guess insecure in himself
a lot of times
they become police officers they're
going to like throw authority
but she would say in broken english you
want me to make
rick cry and we'd be like yeah i would
say yeah everybody would say no but i'd
say [ __ ] yeah let's see
let's see rick was the mace but we knew
it was a broken heart
oh my gosh can you imagine that i would
think though
brutalized him also also remember this
was
from a bygone era that i grew up in
and i had a friend of mine that i worked
with great dude
lost track of him and uh can i say his
name and then
we can block it off yeah um
was his name
i worked in northridge good dude he
almost looked like
um almost like uh tom hanks had an older
brother
oh yeah he had the same kind of nose and
would go roller skating
at balboa not even at the beach like
balboa park here in the san fernando
valley
and he would hook up with chicks and he
would go to zims i remember zim
yeah of course i remember jim's was a
restaurant and you would go in there
and this was the 70s everybody had pelo
and nobody wore a condom and they just
be shooting
grandma everywhere you know nobody they
didn't have cell phones
you know they're telling you to get a
smile and try to you know be like you're
almost you're like you know
trying to find zims or black angus or
red onion
or you know kathy skeleton
and um so everybody would went to go to
those places
and was quite the you know he was quite
the roller skater
and i and i wasn't you know so he would
say to me come with me i never went
roller skating with him
and he would be like come with me man
you know i mean all these chicks out
there and i said how do you meet him he
just you know he's good looking dude
yeah so i go to his apartment he has an
apartment on reseda
worked with me at a bmw like this dude
was like rick springfield but he worked
in northridge
you know you know what i mean like yeah
yeah
baby the guy yeah they out there from
loverboard before not right now
yeah if you threw a singer a lover boy
over the mountain with someone he'll
come back up
oh and finish and wrap it up
everybody's wet so so
so so here's why i never heard
anyone else tell me so i'm a chicano
dude
i go to his apartment on sunday sh she
brings her friend for me
and they're both latinas and we have
drinks around the balcony
and she says to to her friend
that she's only using for his money and
what he can do
for her i don't think if they knew that
i understand spanish and at work i
told him and oh man they got in a big
fight and she came to work
and like confronted me and i've really
never been
confronted you know like in your early
20s and somebody
is waiting further in the car that's on
and gets out and she's you know yelling
in your face and i i told i
i said hey i i heard you say that no we
didn't i heard you said and i told you
i don't i don't know if i don't know man
but that was my dude and i think i told
him and
i think i'm not going to say what
happened because i can't remember but
i'm pretty sure
because i haven't talked to him in 40
years that it didn't go well
yeah and that whenever i left that job i
don't think i saw again but
wow you know but that's a proud moment
and in the three times that that's
happened in my life
every every one of the three times that
i've
been out on the limb to tell somebody
hey maybe this person
isn't what they appear to be to you
that every one of the times that i
stepped up
and spoke out cost me the friendship
with that person
but it worked out the way you thought it
you
had warned them about it like you warned
them i know
hello which one is this one [ __ ] gary
gilmore over here sour hill
but it worked out the way you told you
told them it was going to right it
didn't work out well for them
you warned them but then it i thought of
your friendship i could have said
nothing
yeah and you've been friends they would
have been double
yeah well two times but
whatever whatever you know that's a good
question do you want
would you like a friend to tell you
something that they know that you don't
know yeah
yeah what's the number it's eight one
you know what is the number but do you
want it is it is it better to know
or not to know
i mean no one's going to be 100 honest
but if you see somebody like i saw
somebody
at a restaurant in northridge that those
two people thought
they were away from people and then i
went in there
and saw them in the back booth and
um i told uh it was it was a friend of
mine's brother and i
didn't talk to that guy after really no
kidding
either i'm really full of [ __ ] or no one
uh takes any kind of
friendship looking at a friend that is
being honest to you exactly and when you
see it coming but if somebody if the
girl said like she said
he's just telling you that because he
wants me oh
that worked that worked on one guy but
if anybody you know knows me you could
look at her and look at me and go
he wouldn't ever get that conversely
so no i would say no so you know
and do you let it still continue i would
say i would say
i'm gonna say no because i don't think
anybody wants
to be lied to or to be treated
um is that disrespect or to be to be um
off the right track no uh like i'm also
you know
to have an illusion as a relationship
yeah
well uh i'll be at excalibur thursday
try the veal it's an illusion i uh i
uh on the other hand i try to talk to my
friends out of getting married
and uh they both got married and stay
with their wives for 20 plus years
i was coming what did you say wrong i
said i told the one guy
at least if the guy could say listen hey
man i value your opinion like somebody
we know
yeah um yeah but also if you're a friend
man maybe
and you say listen i appreciate it but i
got you know i got it from here
yeah well i mean you know me i i kind of
don't like to ruffle feathers anyway i
have trouble with conflict in in
in most areas and i told this guy is
that why every time we go out we get
[ __ ] hammered because i said hey you
want another beer you and you can't say
no
well that's that's me and the alcoholic
in me too um
i i told this guy ah before i got
married i go okay
don't get married you don't want to get
married i can tell you don't get married
she doesn't love you for who you are she
loves you or what you could do for her
i wouldn't get married if you please
don't get married and and
at his wedding he's in vegas i said get
my car
we'll drive i will support you man you
don't need to be married right now
because he's looking at other chicks
he's talking to the girls i'm all this
is not a good thing for you you're gonna
lose
you sure this isn't the wedding singer
without those out there
so it was an all-black wedding exactly
yeah i uh and then uh he gets married
and i'm i'm the only white dude
at the wedding and he's all why don't
you stand up and say something when they
say when they get their chance a mall
dude that wasn't gonna happen and he was
my he was a great great friend of mine
uh he was married for many men he's
still married today to her
and then um my other friend i said but
do you think that that it was what it
was and she toned it down
or the relationship continued like the
way they were going
i think he's the one he's the one who
dialed it in he was a guy
who probably shouldn't have been getting
married at the time in my opinion but
then he
obviously he was a great husband and a
great father and it's the whole night
you know
um he locked it in to be elusive isn't
as easy
anymore so you know you almost have to
think that monogamy
um has thrived in the
era of the phone and the era of facetime
and the era of
being connected because it's not like
you can say oh you know i went to bed
and i didn't hear that you called yep
they facetime you
or text you there's a way to get a hold
of you
that wasn't there weren't as many
avenues
yeah in our day where you could say i
fell asleep watching tv that [ __ ] don't
work anymore
yeah and there's a way to know exactly
where you are they can they could track
your phone
even if they're not in touch with you
yeah that's why onstar
yeah i'm starting to get it was a
brilliant idea but if you have a
satellite that could tell
somebody's old lady from monrovia that
he was at the spearmint rhino in van
nuys
you don't want that that service in your
life god
uh how about that no i'm sorry well now
now if you let your significant other
kids anyone
give them your phone information they
can tell exactly where you are 24 hours
a day they know exactly where you are
like my
stepdaughter could could tell me to tell
my wife where i'm at right now
only because i like gave her my
information to get to buy something or
something at some point
and she'll she knows exactly where i'm
at you're doing giving people your
information i don't know it's family i
think it's okay and then you
don't realize they get all this stuff
are you serious wow i don't think she's
got mine to be honest with you but i
mean
if she could if i did she definitely got
my wives
she's got to look out for her she does
oh she's got marcy's yeah
cause she's always looking up and she's
worried about her all the time because
where are you are you okay
oh man i don't know she does exactly
she's my friend over there some
see some spyware goddamn [ __ ] a sex cult
oiler yeah well
everybody thought paulo is changing each
other's phone numbers everywhere that's
one of my favorites
i could never say that to my wife
everyone throw a little apology on the
spot ranch
all right let's all right let's do uh
let's do another one because this one's
kind of interesting this is from the new
york times which is actually something
we're familiar
with dot com new york man kept sharks in
his pool in his basement
come on man the [ __ ] shark in
the water ah you have to be salt water
you just can't have a [ __ ] pool with
a shark in there
right uh oh man
and what kind of shark uh he uh he had
five
sharks coming right here because when
the authorities come in here
the dick shark is gonna get you old dick
shark could get you tonight
um when the authorities made it search
in 2017 jaws in the original jaws
stephen spielberg was a young director
he didn't know that
bruce the shark the minute they put that
[ __ ] in the salt water
he wasn't going to be able to bite uh uh
barnaby whatever that motherfucker's day
was
clef jo what was his name man what was
robert shaw's character
with the cleft [ __ ] um
oh [ __ ] i lost my i got it when he went
and scratched his
yeah that was a special effect in our
day yeah robert shot whatever
and put his finger knows that everybody
in the theater is like yeah
or some rubber [ __ ] head that comes
out of the left of the screen yeah
everybody flips out or the foot the foot
that was still in the shoe floating back
that was like my uncle my cousin i got
hit by a train uh
hey you guys keep it down in there he
made a cameo uh um
but i don't know how this dude's keeping
sharks in this pool come on man that's a
little
okay if i throw the morton salt on the
bottom epsom salts
they keep dying yeah uh they
uh authorities made a surge in 2017 home
of a man who had recently been spotted
in georgia with five small sharks in the
back of his truck
how do you how does that happen oh that
that's like a [ __ ] petting zoo where
i grew up like
like a little [ __ ] hammerhead shark
you could you could kiss it that guy
would hold the tail
like you could kiss it or pet it right
sell baskets of bread for the kids
yeah yeah dollar you know the little
monkey on the chain like little guy then
i grab your nuts
you know he could do two tricks but if
you're like hey what else can you do
here grab your
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuerno with all this
might his little monkey strength
man if he's that strong you think
there's no way that little [ __ ] chain
can hold him but i guess
it does is that [ __ ] monkey grip a
little stretch armstrong
he grip that [ __ ] oh man your dick would
go through his fingers you know it's
like
clay claymation don't ever let a monkey
[ __ ] grab your nuts
that's what we got that's what we
gleaned from the new york times story
today don't ever don't ever let a monkey
grip your nuts people go to like you
know el salvador monkeys out there
dancing ladies dresses
and it's cute for 30 seconds and they
realize that you don't
you know have food like they wanted
they'll [ __ ] take that long monkey
thumb and put it right in your oil
you're wearing some loose fitting shorts
the rest of your trip you won't be so
excited to go to machu picchu you got a
[ __ ] monkey thumb in your cool little
first night there
ah jesus
so anyways there's the guys sharks are
those [ __ ] and those
[ __ ] just live everywhere man
do you think you're in a five-star hotel
a [ __ ] monkey under the bed
oh god the loose-fitting shirts man
it's gonna stay with you you're running
your balls are [ __ ] hanging out
they'll grab you with a long ass arm
oh jeez there's no way man so what
happened to do that sharks in there
whatever
they kept dying they uh they found uh
the carcasses unfortunately
uh uh of two leopard sharks and a
hammerhead shark
i'm a snout of an endangered small tooth
sawfish
that's horrible maybe the dude's just
trying to make medicine for you know for
for bangkok he uh joshua seguin they eat
all that stuff you know in some
countries yeah they eat everything they
shoot a tiger
yeah you make soup out of the bone and
you think you can you know outside
[ __ ] elevate yourself in life because
you ate some
[ __ ] tiger bone soup yeah that's
ridiculous right
you think that's like the greatest thing
in the world and it's eye of the tiger
that song was written but i do had
i had a tiger like some soup
i almost i almost bought that i'm like
really
back to the street
i remember the number eight one eight
five three three one eight four three
that
was i don't remember the question though
uh would it be safe to tell your friends
something that they don't know
yes that you have privy killer champ
right that's from dick collins
818-533-1843
and that's our news we can go to some
voicemails
ratch wretchedness oh we got headphones
on good
we hit him on the whole time it makes my
hair look better
now we need him george how's it going
long time fan
i was listening to your podcast and you
were talking about stories of uh
when you lived in the san fernando
valley i actually live on san fernando
and balboa um so my question is what
other
memories do you have of growing up in
the valley hope
you know and when you used to get in
trouble or enemies tv stories
let me know take care well all right the
guy lives on san fernando in balboa san
fernando balboa they did that was where
the treasury was
that was where um what was the dude's
name from fast times of richmond high
the the judge weinhold oh judge reinhold
was uh what was his name
um um can't remember his name
brad brad yeah that's where he's driving
when he's wearing the out the captain's
outfit when he
has to go deliver pirate outfit and
nancy wilson pulls over or
the girl from the heart yeah not the not
the one with niacin but the other one
the skinny one
and anna nancy and uh
right there on balboa that's where the
first band store was in the valley
there was a treasury there's a great
jack in the box right there on balboa
near like
devonshire de soto right up in the right
there and um
near grenada hills where jonathan we hit
the the light yep and and
um all that stuff man like in uh
northridge the skate place where people
would come like from different
neighborhoods
we weren't welcome there devonshire
downs jimi hendrix played devonshire
downs which is right down from there uh
they would have you know the fair there
uh the doors play the demonstrator downs
jimmy henderson we used to go watch
wrestling
i followed me mascaras to his car there
at everything
that was like an 11 year old and then we
became friends later in life and he
signed a mask
that's awesome and i started crying when
i got it super my birthday yeah
that's awesome in a few days but then so
really everything that was kind of
happening was happening right there
where that dude lives cheech grew up
right there by
oh yeah san fernando mission and uh
balboa
wow um but that guy's in the right place
man that's right
the valley's the valley was the valley
girl the mall all that stuff was great
i lived on devonshire and zelda and uh
right there yep and devonshire and
balboa was where one of the early in and
outs was as well
and now burgers it was right right there
early on there was one over there by me
san fernando where laurel canyon and san
bernardino mission 1973.
that was the second one that's way early
yeah that's super yeah and then uh let's
see the brady bunch house or student
city oh
oh yeah the vow it was a hundred and all
right
degrees i was back in the oh hundred ah
thousand degrees
man those were some good days man yep i
think you know
there was less people weren't as uh
i don't know man it's just maybe there
were better people i don't know
we uh we're crossing the street nobody
knows their neighbor or anything now
yeah back then it says hello back then
it was like you had to
or you you weren't you weren't hiding or
you weren't unf you don't
love thy neighbor that whole all that
kind of stuff there was a show called
love that neighbor yep
and they made they made a porno out of
that one i loved the neighbor they took
vi
out and they put the and it's all
everybody at the community pool thorn
gang bang on melissa pleasures yeah you
had to pick that v8
at the lobby
yeah so uh uh the val well he said get
into trouble what was uh
what was some of the trouble you got
into oh oh i mean you've already
you've already talked about a lot of
that about a couple duis one uh cool
one there at uh sepulveda and by matt
and tony's
fox but uh overall you know by the bear
pit right there on september not far
from where this guy lives
uh there was a lot of great places to
get in trouble back there it's pulved up
when i
when i lived i lived off of uh sepulveda
and roscoe yeah a little rough and then
um there was a lot of
mahogany wagons over there yeah a lot of
professionals right there
eight ball cabaret uh eight ball cabaret
andy one of the dudes that called last
weekend in las vegas at 12 30 in the
morning
the one that said hey what'd you call it
tell me everything i did wrong
andy andy says addy says to me amen i'm
playing a pool tournament you know come
and watch me at the eight ball cabaret
that pool tournament
oh no and um as i walk in i guess the
game started i guess he scratched at the
eight ball into the first shot
and as i walk in he's shaking hands with
the dude it's over
that's awesome i didn't tell him that
when i called him at 12 30 in the
morning i had to say that one for the
next time i call him
uh yeah the valley was a great the
valley is world famous but at that time
it was making this place
it was a great place to grow up and back
in the time rubens was one of the places
you go to the party
that was like rubens and uh and uh and
uh
black angus those were big big black
angus was a good place i guess
right there uh stuart anderson
yeah the uh uh onion uh right on yeah
yeah
yeah don cuckoos elgato on uh
was a place that you could go under you
get blown right there while you're
waiting for your entree
you get there you're like you know what
i'm not even hungry anymore that's right
the bus boy comes right up to you
uh el presidente oh yeah come on
that was great betty bruce is buried
right there across the street from
president than that in the
oh how did the jewish mortuary there wow
i didn't know that
lenny bruce that's where lenny bruce
said he fell out he died and whatever he
died
he died he had a needle in his arms he's
over there by the he's over there by him
wow
where i was they probably go put them
over there by george both [ __ ] over
there
all right but your balance is buried
right there it's the same one as
oh wow why what's he doing and also
william was like william slatey
here we go who was barney rubble's voice
so he's in the same graveyard bob hope
is buried in the same place
that a portion of my grandmother is and
my grandfather
and um richie valance wow
well that's him he's probably going hey
can i get moved somewhere else i'll tell
you
there's not a lot of room in here i'm
glad
but but uh uh it's the only mortuary
that they had to tell the farmers there
was a farm that get the
[ __ ] go grow corn somewhere else three
people are dying really they they had to
shut them down today to move them out oh
wow crazy it was a small cemetery
growing up
and now my grandma want to be married
next to dennis weaver she loved mccloudy
i thought it's not to happen
not your grandmother dennis weaver i
think my ernie's called my grandfather
dennis weaver because
my grandmother was so creative about
mcleod oh wow
great show he used to do bank
commercials in his mcleod giant after my
grandfather at all she would try to go
find a basketball to dribbling
when i was doing my show her dog's name
was mccloud
it was a german shepherd that chased us
out of the kitchen and that dog's name
was mcleod no kitty
man my grandmother loved dennis uh
weaver yeah and she would even say it
because i would go to like you know
farrell's or something where i saw john
was eating ice cream
and uh which was right there on rosita
and demonstrate and she would say
jordan have you seen dennis mccloud time
to come over here because everything i
got is his
horn there's no need to eat ice cream
after that
uh at pharaoh's where they would sell
kids ice cream with little pieces of
uh that's awesome
and then they buy you that licorice that
long licorice yeah and then you take the
licorice you tell
ernie i go and see if this licorice is
longer than
that dude because your mom is sitting
next to
and then they would take off yeah what
was that show that they were all on
dennis weaver heck ramsay
um what was that so they all came by
there was like uh
it was old school rawhide no it was
pretty much but it was seven brides for
seven
it was with the uh susan st james and
rock hudson was on that too
uh oh oh the mystery the nbc mysteries
yeah that's what it was yeah mystery
macmillan and white yeah yeah mcmillan
life yeah they were all in the same kind
of thing right the wife would have to be
in there
it's mcmillan yeah and not macmillan and
macmillan
he's like macmillan and wife like that
[ __ ] had to be in there somewhere
right like you're not gonna let you put
your name unless you put let everybody
know you're married
did you actually you think she was hot
uh what was her name
susan st james i did
i thought she was like way too young for
rock hudson you know one of the things
about
having some notoriety right now is that
if i wanted to go out there and bang out
a couple of ladies that
were actresses yeah you know lily
munster's gone
philly d from vegas is gone but there
might be a couple over there in the home
over there
you might go in there you're like is
that the lady from mr ed and just by
going there
i used to have a crew what if you saw
somebody you know like
uh let's see who was hot uh uh uh the
girl from emergency dixie
what if she oh it was in her retirement
home right there where you grew up in
zelda and balboa yeah
uh dixie with their their smokey or um
um there's plenty of them oh what other
one um
or uh you know joan ben arc
um falcons crest
good call let's go to uh lisa arturo
our our pets ah this is i've been
excited about having her not this is
gonna be great
she's greatest no she's a beautiful
individual i'm sure i met her six years
ago she's a wonderful woman
today's guest for george is uh wonderful
actress
dude it's hard to get started the worst
but it's hard to get started on these i
wouldn't even let you announce high tide
it's high tide [ __ ] lifeguard
somebody else gotta do it
at three o'clock it's hi
okay uh let me let me know if i missed
any actress
dog expert animal activist rescue
warrior and
pet matchmaker and tango dancer
tang oh lisa arturo
um yeah um
i don't know where to start let's see um
how many dogs do you think that i've
read how many do you what did you say 20
i'm i'm guessing somewhere there i asked
you earlier i couldn't we couldn't come
down with a number
a lot um it's time for
the honest moment okay
um when i was growing up
all my emotion was negative
crying fear loneliness
abandonment uh isolation
never was it you know happy
um excited
all of it was negative and in
in the body of that it's growing up you
you build these
kind of like you know everybody says
walls but
you're not gonna let anybody get near
you
because you just kind of already know
that they're not going to stay they're
going to go
you know in in life you know so
in picking you know it's funny that my
therapist is like
well look what you did you picked a
profession that you you're the only
person out there
and then you picked a game that you
could play by yourself golf
so between playing the guitar you could
do by yourself
golfing and doing stand-up
i chose the things that i enjoy in my
life that don't
require me connecting to anybody
and uh when i was married
i would i would like to believe that and
kind of had the idea that
i was you know [ __ ] up is the easy
word but that i was having trouble
this i was very disconnected to emotion
and um that
you know you wouldn't want somebody to
comply
just because they feel like they have to
because that's false
so i played a part of somebody that
was you know trying to be a father to
mayan
was great but i didn't have a father and
i didn't see that stuff so all that
stuff was really
very painful to me like christmas is you
know she would do big christmases
and i didn't have really christmases so
when sh when i met her instead of having
a little christmas
we had [ __ ] big christmases and they
just
make you feel worse right because you
have this big thing and you don't know
how to celebrate
or thanksgiving with all these people
over and even when i did my
my the first show the first year
2002 thanks thanksgiving or even when
we started to go back in august because
i was you know solitary as a comedian
and then all of a sudden you have a tv
show
and then you have the summer off and
then you come back to work
in august and everybody's like good
morning good morning good morning
good morning good morning i go to my
room i'm like [ __ ] man this is
this is going to be a pain in the ass
man everybody
you know saying [ __ ] good morning
there's so many people [ __ ] hey man
people wanted to touch me because you
know the show they were like oh it's so
sweet they want to touch me i would say
like hey
i really don't like anybody anybody
touching me and they were like
oh okay no no i mean you know i'm sure
you're fine but just
i just really you don't like people
putting their hands on me
so we made a joke out of it don't touch
the talent
so so but but the first
the first thanksgiving that we had as a
show
and the woman who played my mom belita
you know everybody had a list of what
they were going to bring food they were
going to bring so you know bracarios and
all that stuff so you have
this long table where the whole
show was gonna eat like 170
people like a roll of tables and other
tables
and then me at the head of the table
so when it was time to eat i went to my
dressing room
and i i hid out in there while they were
eating
people were like you know eating and
then i remember valentine came over and
he's like he knocked on the door
he goes well what are you doing i said i
can't go out there man he's like what do
you mean
i said i i i you know i don't feel
comfortable going out there goes but you
know you got to come out there and say
nah
you know i kind of can't because i think
it's the idea of something
that's family that everybody got along
was
foreign to me so i'd rather be by myself
than to be sitting
in the stage with 150 people who
are all working on the same thing and
all very happy so
when i when you and i worked together in
15 2015. and then when you said to me
i asked you what you did and you said i
rescue
i i pet rescue dogs and cats i guess
right
animal rescue for mostly dogs dogs and
cats
so she said to me something that changed
my life she said
have you ever watched any videos on
youtube of animals being rescued
and i said i never have she goes you
know
the organization you were working with
at that time i looked
and i saw myself i saw
a chihuahua on the porch that wouldn't
let anybody near him
it was biting people and just horrific
he's in the corner showing teeth and
then the guy sits there
and he's sitting there and then he's
sitting there and he
puts a towel you know when he's trying
to touch a dog with the towel of dogs
biting the towel
and through you know simple acts of like
kindness
the dog starts to trust this guy
and they you know they put the what's
that a leash call do you guys call it uh
it's called a sn
a snappy pull a snappy snare and snappy
snap
and um you know
and then they'll cut to two weeks later
and the [ __ ] dog's got a dress on
they've been beaten down so much they
don't
they they're trying to protect
themselves but they come around and
that's the thing that
fascinated me by watching those things
and really if you watch one you're going
to watch
10 and it's going to look like it's an
hour and really five hours have gone by
and and you know it changed the way that
i think it changed the way that i that i
lived
because i used those examples of
something looking hopeless and rescuing
i mean
you you've seen uh
animals in horrific shape
left behind um right and they all run
and they're all they run they hide
they're
they're you know you don't know if
they're they they don't want to bite but
out of fear sometimes they don't trust
you so there you have to be careful
um they they just you don't know what
their past is and so you
have to give them a second chance but
you have to like do it in a way where
they can trust you or at least they know
that you're not going to hurt them
um can you tell me a little bit
about your background like where you're
from and how what did you aspire to be
when you know earlier in your life and
yeah how you got to where you are
i'm from jersey i'm a jersey girl
italian girl from jersey
and came out here to act so uh did you
come out here by yourself
i did i came out here to act and to
dance so i i had a dance background i
was a dancer
in new york city and traveled around
with different dance companies
lived in europe lived in japan and then
moved out to
los angeles to act because um i couldn't
sing
my singing was really bad so i would
audition for broadway shows and they
were like
and then i was like okay well i'm just
gonna stick with acting and came to la
and um you know did that for for a long
time
um as as an actress it's all about me me
me me
and i kind of got tired of just it all
being about me
so i um i i
my dog that i had that i had uh my that
was out here with me for about 12 years
he had passed away and it was so hard
just passed away didn't he
well that was that was recently yes but
then at the time when i got into rescue
my
personal dog had passed away and i was
just devastated and i remember thinking
myself like what am i going to do i
can't shake this off
and this like voice came to me and said
just be of service
and so i decided did you really hear
something yeah
i did i just was like you because it was
too much
pain it was so much pain and it was like
i needed to get out of it i was like do
something
outside of yourself not acting
not worrying about you know not going to
a therapist and talking about my dog
dying i wanted to do something and so i
just went into a shelter
i went into south central and i walked
into the shelter and i saw what was
going on you just you just went to south
central shelter and you walked in
yeah cold and you said hey i'm here well
first i just walked around and said let
let's see what's going on in here and
then
i can see these animals they were like
sitting in their urine and who was
in the corner shaking and like george i
hear my grandmother
and everything you know and because i'm
italian bossy girl from jersey i was
like why doesn't he have any water why
doesn't this one have a blanket what's
going on with that one over there and i
said okay i have to sign up like today
to become a volunteer and so i started
working in the shelter systems for
as a volunteer for many years do you do
you think
that
people neglect animals like that
and hurt them and mistreat them
because there's no really really way for
them to kind of
voice their you know people come home
and they're mean to dogs and
yeah you know they they they let them
loose and they
beat them and then there's and and
the most unconditional love is i think
an animal
there's some dude that was [ __ ]
sleeping with a fox if you get a fox
from the [ __ ] woods
to [ __ ] wear a harness and this
[ __ ] is walking a fox to the
starbucks i mean it's a fox
you're like man this dude could be
kissing a fox on a
mouth all happy yeah eating a macacino
whatever you serve your food that you
gave your dog one right
with like whipped cream it's starting to
have a puppuccino
you know as a way to like kind of
eliminate their troubles almost like
they just we as
rescuers we constantly ask ourselves
this all the time because we're always
seeing people that
abandon their dogs or abuse them i think
that they're struggling and they're in
so much pain themselves a lot of people
like are struggling financially or in in
their relationships or whatever it is
and
they just don't know how they don't know
what to do with this animal so they'll
either abuse it or they'll abandon it
i get phone calls all the time like you
know oh we're getting a divorce
oh you're getting a divorce yes so can
you take the dog well wait a minute
your wife can't take the dog and you
can't you're both moving to places
and neither one of you could commit to
finding housing
that will take the dog this is so
confusing to me
well yeah well if you don't take it
we're gonna we're gonna drop it off at
the shelter
has it been spayed or neutered no
listen if i see a dog with his balls
i think that dude is like old school
like studio 54 1978
you know because everybody neuters their
dogs so when you see one that's
that still has testicles as you know
maybe five years or
more right you're almost like why would
he still
do that right okay so
gotta chop them off here's a okay here
this is a good question because i don't
think i've ever
why do people neuter their male dog why
do they remove their testicles
well first of all if you don't neuter
your dogs they're going to mark
everywhere in your house okay because
they're like this is my spot this is my
spot they just want to claim territory
okay
and they're marking because they're
claiming their territory even in a house
right yeah in dominance they're just
like you know they they they have all
this testosterone they're gonna mark
their areas this is mine this is mine
and if there's other dogs in the house
then you have a competition happening
you're like okay well you're gonna pee
there well i'm gonna pee on top of it
you know just to like
and then you have a disaster and
everyone's saying gang tags yeah
other and the other reason is you don't
we don't need any more puppies in the
world right so if you're having your
dog's not neutered and it gets out and
they have an accidental
pregnancy then then you know we have
another
and then and then what happens to those
dogs is because they're not
professional breeders or they're not
rescuers they're like oh
my dog had puppies and then the cousin
wants one and then the neighbor wants
one and everybody's handing out puppies
nobody's getting vaccinated or spayed
and neutered and they're making more
animals
and everybody wants a puppy but guess
what at eight months nine months old
this puppy is now a big dog and it's a
pain in the ass
and their kids don't want to play with
it anymore and oh you know what i got
this dog from my neighbor their
litter puppies and it was but now we can
and we're going on vacation and
can you take the dog do
um do people
just get a dog because as you grow up
you think that
you have the house and the picket fence
and kids
and the dog right right are people
getting dogs
as a symbol do they love the dogs like
if you had a dog for seven years
i think it would be difficult to just
let them go
or take them to the shelter is a big
deal because in my neighborhood they
would just
let them go like and this is another
reason i think
you know i don't i don't it could be
cultural
but i did this in my stand-up when i was
starting like when the dog got sick
you know my grandfather said when it
gets dark we'll take him for a ride
and we did so we'll have this dog in the
backseat with me
and we drive to
an area not near our house like granada
hills
into like some streets then my
grandfather pulls over
and he says open the door and let the
dog out
and i'm like i don't open the door and
let the dog
out just open the door the dog gets out
my grandfather has his foot on the
brakes and the red light is in the back
and i see the dog go like this
and us pull away and he's doesn't know
what's going on
yeah and um i mean
you don't want to i don't think it's one
community i just think you know
the way people are brought up is the way
they treat dogs you think
in a sense um it everybody has people
have different relationships to animals
so
like it just depends how that human has
a relationship to that animal so if it's
really a pet and it's a family member
you're never gonna open up the door and
just let it go
but also too like we don't know did your
grandfather at the time
not have the finances to take him to
this no it was just it was a nuisance
like
they always want everything to be
perfect so if you're [ __ ] in the house
out no first of all no dog was in the
house
right not now they sleep on the bed they
have their own beds
sweaters your pillow
they were always outside yeah and uh
when my grandfather died
that's a pretty sad story i bought i
bought my grandmother samoyen
puppy and she
didn't spend any time with him he was a
great dog dean i call him dean
and didn't spend any time with them and
she told me she did but when i would go
over he'd be in the backyard all the
time and just in the house it didn't
look like
he was ever in the house and um
my grandma was lying to me like oh no
she's in here you watch tv's at my feet
and all that and uh he probably lived to
be like 12 and then
i took him to the i had to put him down
i took him to the vet
and i carried him in a blanket and
i apologize to him for
for mistreating him because i
i i was like hey man i let you i'm sorry
i let you down like i apologize to him
for not giving him a better life i said
sure taking you with
that's a tough that's a tough run right
but i think but i think
in people wanting a pet
yeah okay you want a pet but
the reason why there's so many is
the people let them go and then there's
right
well in my rescue um at big love animal
rescue i've
i have an application that's like four
pages long so if you want a dog
you have to answer everything you have
to fill out a very detailed application
i need videos of your house i need to
meet your whole family like i need to
know that this family
this dog is going to be with you for
life that it's going to live inside
and that you have the financial means to
take care of it if not you don't get one
of my dogs
end of story that's it do you think
that's the biggest reason people get rid
of dogs is financial
i think it is i think it's i think you
know everybody likes the idea of it it's
like oh yeah my kids are pain in the ass
let's get it a puppy or a dog so we
don't have to like you know and then
they do that kind of thing right and
then the kids get tired of it or the dog
has got a skin issue or there's medical
stuff that comes up and it's expensive
the the veterinarian costs for animal
care is
outrageous and then someone's like well
you know what he's throwing up but
uh he'll be okay because that last vet
bill was 1200
so i don't want to deal with this again
and they and they and then they just
like you know becomes a nuisance yeah so
okay so in this in this last year that's
been very difficult and
and why are why why are veterinarian
bills so much
why are they so why are they so much
because it's a business
it's a business they're making money
they're making sure you don't need to
they don't need to charge that much no
they don't even even in
in rescue i'll get like 15 or 20 off
and you know like um i had a dog that
i rescued from tijuana and she was so
sick she was
she went into the bushes to die in
tijuana and these people found her and
brought her
to san diego and then i picked her up
and she cost me eight thousand dollars
to save her life and she had two
tick-borne diseases and that eight
thousand dollars was with
my discount and she had with the
discount yeah she had two blood
transfusions she was on iv
fluids she was in emergency hospitals
and i and because she was
slowly getting better and i just feel
like once they're in my rescue it's my
responsibility to do everything i can
and i promised her that i was going to
try to give her a better life and so
i paid 8 000 but she she does need a
home and she is
so happy and healthy now wow amazing
for the people that don't have the
resources like that
what can they do um always reach out to
rescue groups and ask them if they have
any resources
unfortunately the shelters have limited
medical care so
um they really have no medical they
really don't have any medical care but
you can call them and ask them if they
know of any low cl
low-cost clinics or hospitals or surgery
centers
and you can also do things if you don't
have the finances for it is start a
a gofundme or start a fundraiser and
people
it's like a family member so you do the
same thing if it was a child
right you're like hey my my animal's
really sick i don't have the money for
this
neighborhood chips in 10 bucks here 20
dollars here
try to like get a fundraiser going and
you know support
support people in your community or
support your your family members
you know this last sunday um i got a
call at seven o'clock in the morning
from a guy that i know that lives in his
car and he says um
was that willy galt no
no but you think willie because he's
already already working out at 7am
and willie gaulth is the only dude that
played professional football
30 years ago that still looks like he
could still play oh my god he's amazing
unbelievable willie galt a
little on my football card when i was in
college my favorite player
willie galt 1985. thank you for that fun
fact thank you she's a good friend
yeah anyway this lady died in her car
and um in granada hills in the park and
she
and she was like she had slept and she
moved back and the dog this gigantic
senior dog
like 70 pounds was wedged in the back
seat
so i got there and you know i said to
the cops i don't want this dog to go to
animal i don't want to go to the shelter
because she's 14 and her owner died and
so this was the owner can i take the dog
anyway three hours later we waited for
the coroner to come
and uh the cops wouldn't touch the dog
because the police
are separate from animal control so
since i was taking the place of animal
control
there were like four big dudes standing
around cops
and they're like okay well you can take
the dog so i had to like climb in the
back of the car there was glass
everywhere and
i had to like pull this gigantic dog out
of the back
and i looked at her and i was like you
know i know that you're
you know your owner died and i'm gonna
i'm not gonna let you go to the shelter
and
it's gonna be okay and so i have her i
have her in a foster home right now
she's 14 she's got terrible hips and i
got her
700 worth of medical care you know
um when you were growing up did you like
pets did you did you have dogs
you know what i had a dog but i wasn't
like
all about pets i just i was really more
about dancing
oh yeah yeah but but so
i did grow up with a pet i had a family
pet but it changed the direction of your
life right
like i i can't see you not being
involved in oh i'll always do it from
now on
it's like my thing you know i mean i'm
supposed to do it
and and you've been so great you you've
been so wonderful with
helping us out and he has two he has two
big love dogs
alex leela um uh
the one that i got from tijuana oh yes
yes yeah
yeah she was poor thing she died
yeah so she smelled pretty bad i mean
you know with with the you got her right
you found her tijuana and he came to me
and she said no she had a broken jaw
but it wasn't broken it just because she
had such bad dental disease that it just
deteriorated her entire bottom jaw and
that's why it smelled so bad
so we got her the dental remember we got
a dental and jordan
this dog was in my house for the first
time i went downstairs i said
it smells like i was so bad
i called her i said listen man if this
dog can't get rid of the smell
it's got to go yeah and we got her
dental and he texts me and he goes oh my
god the bill was like 8
000 right oh man
yeah and she was maybe like what 12
maybe yeah
she was like 12. and i said george we
don't have to do all that stuff we're
just going to get her teeth like
cleaned and we're going to do
extractions and we got her fixed up and
it was
and and her breath was fine right she
lived for like another breath
did i have less than a year maybe you
had about about eight months
yeah so yeah i brought her into the
house
she was great took her i take him out
every morning
and in the middle of the night i heard
her
kind of like yelping and
she was yeah she was dying in your arms
right
oh my god thank you for being there for
her and i
you know i'd never seen any pet go
through that
and it was really painful to to
to see that and also the idea that
this dog had been so abused and yet was
so loving i mean listen
there's a lot of people that i don't
talk to because of the past they can't
we can't get past
our own past as human beings and but a
dog will
forget all of that and that's a tony
larussa yeah the man
baseball manager started this thing in
san francisco arf
because he would he was the manager of
like the oakland aids and he would
listen to the radio and they would be
talking about him
he's like well i'm gonna listen to the
radio and then he went and adopted a dog
and the dog was there when he came home
dog would run up to him and he's like
this is what this is what
this is what i need and totally and he
started a foundation
in um in oakland yeah
yeah yeah and then and then ut took two
more chihuahuas alex and eddie
yeah yeah what's the mistake that people
make when they have well first of all
why shouldn't someone buy a dog and why
are two questions why are puppy mills
still around
because i want years ago we went to
oxnard they were selling chihuahuas
for like 50 bucks and we went and looked
at one they were
covered in fleas like a thousand fleas
on this little dog
and we never went back to get it but wha
why how did that still exist the thing
with uh backyard breeders
and um people that want to get dogs
online they go online they look at the
website the puppy's in a pretty little
basket they're like oh i have to have
that dog i don't care that it's four
thousand dollars
but you don't know where it's coming
from and these are all backyard breeders
they're just
the dogs are kept in deplorable
conditions
people just want to want what they see
on the on the internet and they'll spend
that money and because
everybody's buying dogs online these
breeders are continuing to do it i heard
recently someone said that bulldogs are
up to like seven
thousand dollars a dog so if you're in
you know iowa and you've got your
your dogs your puppies there and yours
and people are sending you seven
six seven thousand dollars for a puppy
why would you stop
exactly yeah is is a is a seven thousand
thousand dollar dog is it you don't and
they pretend they have papers
and they don't and they well you know
they write something up and it's like a
write something like the internet yeah
there's like there's this is like a
special line this breed this dog came
from like
you know champion breeds and who cares
is is there a that that
is removing you know pets from like pet
shops or being able to buy a cat
at petco well now we now in
um in california we don't have pet
stores anymore now we have
there are pet shops but they only have a
rescue dogs
do you remember pet stores yeah but they
we did have pets where they have a
monkey i saw a monkey in their website i
never saw a monkey in here that'd be
awesome
the giraffe went out of all the giraffes
baby hippo in there
but they closed them down they did close
them down
and who were the listen i love a
carnival as much as the next person
but to put your life in the hands of a
dude who hasn't washed his hand in seven
years
and who has no dental he's that one
tooth i got like
everybody in his black black ass oily
hand
and these [ __ ] things spinning all
over the [ __ ] hat flies off
faster [ __ ] all right [ __ ] that
that [ __ ] scrambler
scrambler they just you know break your
hip and
bust your femur and they moved out of
valencia the next weekend
uh and i think that's the people that
that ran
pet shops i think that's because they
were never
it was never a big pet shop it was just
a place you go in there
a little a little storefront pretty much
what they were yeah they still try to
get away with it they try to say oh
these are rescue dogs and you walk you
walk in and there's like a purebred
yorkie in there you know it's just it's
all about money they don't care about
the animals so it's our job
as the general public to you know do
your work and say where am i getting a
dog from
the other thing that i hear a lot is
well i want to make sure that the dog is
going to be good with my
kids and i know that labradoodles and
yorkies they have good personalities and
they're not going to hurt my kid but you
know the truth is is like if you get a
puppy or a dog that's young doesn't
matter what it's mixed with
it's your job to set the dog up to win
and get it some training
and socialize it i mean i've i've i've
adopted out a lot of pitbull puppies to
families and and i make sure they get
training
and set the dog up to win and and they
and they
you know live harmoniously with the kids
and with their entire family
well is the is there's a good question
all right let's see
never mind uh is there something in a
dog that you rescue
that has been too far
gone at all to bring him back to to live
with a family or something like that
what what's that sign
what what do you see in a dog that can't
be socialized
if there is such thing yeah no i i mean
i've been doing this for so many years i
have come across a few dogs that
you know they're just have a little bit
of a something that's
you know you can see it in their eyes
and they're not all there and even
though you've paid for training and
everything there have been a few times
i'm not going to adopt out any dogs that
are human aggressive it's just never
going to happen i mean
humans come first so if a dog has to be
humanely euthanized
i have had to do it a few times it's
devastating but really
mostly i put my dogs in training and i
give them months to to like trust
if someone doesn't have access to
training if a dog
bites somebody what should somebody do
um should they keep the dog
it depends on the situation like it did
that dog bite because
it gave a warning sign like did a young
kid turn around and grab its tail
and it hurt the dog so the dog bit the
kid's hand
so are we gonna are we going to are we
gonna say it's the dog's fault because
the kid did that or did the dog just
come out of nowhere and decide to attack
somebody so i
every situation i have to hear the whole
story and then we have to see like
what's going on with the dog does it
have any medical issues
you know is there an ear infection going
on is it sick and it's not feeling well
and so it responds
it's reactive because of something that
someone did so do we want to put the dog
down or get rid of it because it bit
and it's got uh you know something
medically going on with it
i ask every question like that to make
sure i mean i'm always the advocate for
the animals so
you know so when i was uh in the early
80s
uh this guy george lozano lived in
pacquiao moment in telefair
and he used to paint cars in his garage
and we would go over there
you know to drink beer outside he'd
paint a car and he had a little brother
named javier javier was like would be on
the house and he'd jump off
he was just like a destructive he wasn't
he wasn't afraid of anything
so we go next door to do some bastard
his uh backyard
and there's a doberman on the on a chain
and he runs that javier and javier
doesn't move and he's like
with the teeth and sebastian is
kind of proud that he's like hey tell
javier be careful because you know that
dog will bite
so we turn around and all of a sudden we
hear crazy he grabbed the dog by the
ears and bit him in the nose
oh he bit the dog i thought that was the
guy
that's the kind of kid he was right yeah
so here so but if you but that dog
that's already on a chain
so that person wanted it as a guard dog
he's living on a chain he's
freaking out he doesn't have much of a
life and somebody goes up and does that
to him
so what's what's that dog's life going
to be yeah it's going to be more intense
yeah um oh man what kind of
you're a small dog person right uh no
but i own
i've owned a lot of small dogs i like
big dogs but what makes a person a big
dog because i don't i don't really
i'm not i'm not a big dog
i'm a little dog person yeah i'm a big
dog person but also i felt you know
when i did beverly's chihuahua the first
movie never expected it to be
very good and then when it became a hit
people started adopting chihuahuas or
getting chihuahuas and then when they
realized
that none of those chihuahuas were as
charming as i am
that that they they started to let them
go
and they didn't want them anymore
because you see this movie and they're
that at that that chihuahua they're not
you know they're
they shake and yeah same thing with that
movie of one thousand dalmatians or the
domination everybody was like i want a
dalmatian and then they thought
okay it's not like the dog in the movie
and they were dumping them at the
shelter that
during that movie there were so many
dalmatians in the shelter
no kidding what's the percentage of
people that dump i would say that take a
dog to the shelter as opposed to
just letting it go oh man you know i
don't i don't know because i don't know
those people but i'll tell you what uh
what i'd like to do to them if i saw
somebody dumping a dog
yeah you you know we see that stuff
right that
yeah sad or they just leave them chained
up and just leave them
yeah whatever that's that's that's where
they move out of their house or they get
evicted and they just leave the dogs
with no food or no water in the yard for
days
i have two of those dogs right now
somebody moved out two pit bulls
super sweet and they they left the dog
there with no food or water for days and
animal control
that's the next
um i don't think you even know this
i saw a pit bull in an organization did
i tell you the story in new york
it was a female they were going to put
it down and i said
i'll get it because it looked very
docile and then
it came over to la the guy drove it
and i was gone and wendy who watched the
dog was there and when i came home that
dog oh you tell me the story
he got out showed its teeth and went up
on the
on the fence in there in the house and i
stopped
and wendy was kind of like in shock and
i said hey wendy you want to take that
leash and
put it on this dog and that dog is
showing his teeth
and i said hey wendy can you get me
and she was just kind of like freaked
out i think if i would have turned
that dog would have jumped over that
fence and and i'm sure would have mauled
me
and then even when we called somebody to
come and pick it up i was upstairs
it tried to go upstairs and get me
and um
what's the history of the pit bull like
you know i remember guys in my
neighborhood were trained them to be
mean
and now when you look
it's yeah it's awful to train a dog to
well we don't know the dog's background
right so the one that was in the shelter
in new york
i would i would have asked like does it
have behavioral notes why is it there
how old is it like i would ask the
shelter you know what's the history of
the dog
and then you've got is there anybody can
assess the dog can they do like a dog
test to make sure the dog is friendly
with other dogs how is it with men
how is it with women so there's a whole
bunch of questions that i ask before i
pull a dog from the shelter
because the truth is i'm i'm a pit bull
advocate but there are so many wonderful
pitbulls in the shelter
that deserve to be saved and you know
i'm going to pull out the ambassadors
of the breed from the shelter and save
those have you ever had a pitbull
no my son has a pitbull at this moment
yeah sweetest dog i've ever
so sweet so sweet and the ones that end
up in you know in the shelters that have
behavioral issues it's really sad
because they
it's not that i don't want to save them
but it cost thousands of dollars to turn
them around
sometimes you have a pity for like a
year or two and you know
uh board and train is like fifteen
hundred dollars a month so you need like
thousands of dollars to turn a dog
around and then you don't even know if
it's going to be okay so
you always look for the pit bulls that
are ambassadors of the breeds and there
are
it's really how you raise them you need
to set them up to win
from the beginning so if you've got guys
that are like putting them on chains or
keeping them as guard dogs or you know
making them fight or
not getting them neutered then you're
you're only you're encouraging that
behavior
and so then they don't want them anymore
and they end up in the shelter and
that's somebody else's problem or the
dog gets euthanized
yeah crazy what's what's one of the
first signs to maybe
you have a dog that has behavioral
issues or
maybe need some attention well i mean
the first thing i look at is body
language you know
is it tail is its tail like is it its
tail moving its butt
kind of like this is it stiff and like
that is its ears up or is its eyes
darting so
you can tell if a dog is nervous or if
it's like
friendly or if it's just insecure so
you know you're not going to go up to a
dog that's like has its chest out
and it's tail because people go well
it's tail is she is is wagging his tail
but
a nervous wag is this a friendly wag is
when its whole butt is moving
so this means nervous and i might
i'm gonna i don't know i don't know if i
like you i don't know if i like you so
you have to look at the dog's body
language
and also you know what you can't have a
pitbull on one of those
body harnesses with an extended leash
that you would walk a poodle on you know
you have to make sure you have the right
equipment for an animal that's going to
be able to
understand you know your commands your
commands
and what is dog park etiquette if if you
if someone goes to a dog park what's the
etiquette should the dogs stay on the
because i was always i was always i
never really took my dogs but
i was concerned if you know they start
to fight and stuff like that that
yeah you know one's not on the leash and
one is and that's a good question here's
the dog park rules
if you own a dog that is dog selective
meaning it likes some dogs and it
doesn't like others
don't take your dog to the dog park if
your dog is not spayed or neutered
do not take your dog to the dog park
because if your dog's not neutered and
he happens to be
a submissive dog and there's an alpha
that is not
that is neutered he is going to sense
the testosterone on him and attack
the dog that is not neutered even if he
is
a you know back of the pack dog so you
have to make sure that like oh but i
didn't get my dog neutered and
everybody's attacking it
because all the testosterone smell from
the other alpha dogs are like
he's got his balls let's go get him so
okay say it again say those two again
because that
did you ever notice that i didn't know i
didn't know so if you have a if you have
a back of the pack
dog okay like just more friendly
submissive not alpha
and he's not neutered and then you have
another dog at the dog park who happens
to be
you know an alpha dog but he got
neutered they can say you know they
smell each other's butt they can tell
everything
age if they're sick male female all of
that
so the testosterone they can smell that
and they it might it'll cause
it can cause a fight because they're
like oh
just by sense by pack and mentality
if there's if it starts to be a play it
can turn into
you know a fight and the other thing is
like when the dogs are playing
you want to keep it at a level five six
so if dogs are like
rough housing and stuff when it gets to
like an eight nine like the dogs are
going for the neck they're going for the
front of the legs
you want to break it up and reset like
let's stop go for a walk
because you don't want it to escalate
and then people get in between
try to break up a dog fight and
everybody's screaming and making it
worse
and you know that's where that's i
actually don't like dog parks because i
think you have to be a very responsible
pet owner to take your dogs i don't
think most people are responsible pet
owner i think they have pets i don't
know
if they understand i agree if dogs are
fighting in a dog park
and people try to jump in how do you get
dogs to not fight what do you what do
you do if they're fighting
i mean the if the dog one of the things
you can do if dogs is fighting the dog
that actually
has its mouth on the other dog you want
to go behind it and pick up its back
legs because if you lift its back legs
really high you're hoping that the jaw
drops open right you never want to try
to pull the dog that's being attacked
away because you're just going to be
doing a lot of like
tearing um if you have any kind of like
you know water
anything to like get into the dog's face
that's actually attacking the dog
um but uh yeah and trying not to get
bitten
i i did not know that i i've been in the
middle of dogfights and i've just
here's one thing i want to say if you're
watching your dog and you can see the
body language before you can see if a
fight is going to happen
if you're like with all the things i
just said if it starts off at like a
five and it's getting escalating
and you're like oh i don't like the
sound of that you can avoid a fight
but if you're like on your phone which
most people are not paying attention
and they're talking to each other then a
lot of times not even i think i could do
that with chicanos not with dogs like i
would say hey man
well i know you turned george on to
rescuing dogs
what is your day or week like
as far as rescuing animals it's seven
days a week
all day long you really don't take a
break from it just on my way over here
today someone said oh this dog has been
in the shelter for
six months it's a really sweet pit bull
can you know i'll i'll
pay for a month of training if you can
pull the dog then there's another little
benjy looking dog that's really sick and
somebody turned it in because the owner
didn't have any money for it
and so it's like it's in a lot of pain
in the shelter and they're begging me to
take it so i've got those phone calls
then i get phone calls of people that
are
getting a divorce or having a baby or
there's a dog in a ditch over there and
can you like
drive and get this dog that's under the
car and so i have to pick and choose
like what i can have so you receive a
lot of calls
it seems like you're always you're
reaching out as well though it seems
like you're you're kind of
scared because it says you did the
tijuana thing and you're actually
on the lookout well well no people are
still people in tijuana are
like can you take this mom and baby yeah
do they let you bring them across the
border
uh because i know that there's a bunch
of kids up there putting dog suits on
we just put a lot of boxes oh wow
luggage and we just blankets
i met you six years ago and i'm sure you
don't remember but you taught me how to
how possibly help a dog that's stray and
running in the street right
maybe you could share that too because
there's some bologna yeah so
when you see a stray dog the the last
thing you want to do is start running
after it because then the dog's like oh
my danger danger
so you you want to get down to its level
if the dog is not running
you kind of just sit down don't make eye
contact right away if you have any kind
of food and you can toss some pieces of
chicken or cheese or whatever you have
to try to lure the dog next to you
because they pick up on energy
so if your energy is really common you
don't seem to be a threat
then it's not going to run away i've
seen dogs on the streets that are like
or stray and people that you know like
gardeners or
or postal um workers they're just
they're not looking at the dog so they
just walk
past it and the dog is like oh that's
that guy from the other day they don't
feel threatened by it
so you can't chase a dog you have to be
able to and then if you had some
equipment that would be
great but if you don't and you could
like leash the dog um
and then if not you know at least uh
call rescue or call
hannah yeah because we've all seen
that's been in that scene where there's
a busy intersection and there's a dog
running around you've got 20 people
chasing this dog and it's like chaos
right now
your wife in the parking lot
yeah yeah i mean there's lots of believe
it or not even like on freeways there's
so many dogs that end up on the freeways
where people dump the dogs on the
freeways
oh my gosh that's a that's a hard rescue
to do
what is the pandemic done to the
shelters like well the shelters
are closed down so people can't you
can't
you can't you can still adopt a dog but
you can't go in and see it so you have
to kind of adopt it sight unseen
and that's been really tough so a lot of
rescue during the pandemic have stepped
up
and trying to pull dogs out put them in
foster homes
and get them adopted because you're not
allowed
is animal regulation still going around
and collecting dogs and all that if the
dog's out there
um well i don't i don't work for animal
control but the other day when
i was helping that dog that that lady
that died and i took her dog the cops
that said to me wow i wish you know i
would have
had your card because when the shelters
were closed during the pandemic we were
rescuing
uh we were helping people and we'd see
these animals and say we don't know what
to do with them because animal control
is not coming
so they just would leave them oh man
when did organizations like like yours
start
because i think growing up it was called
the pound
right connotation yeah
i mean i i hope that they've been
going on for many many years um i i when
i like i said when i came to la
back in the 90s um there were definitely
rescue
organizations and there's just not
enough of them
and the other thing is is that people
think like oh god well there's a rescue
is going to take care of it
there's so many animals in the shelter
that just
need help and then even for me i want to
help more but
gosh you know it's so expensive so you
know to take any of these dogs
it's i don't people think i have a brick
and mortar location but they don't yeah
or they're like where's your shelter
oh this fairy tale land of you know dogs
frolicking
like i want to help i want to help you
do that i think maybe with the sales of
the beer
a percentage of it should go to the
foundation
but thank you so much for coming i mean
what i mean that's such a help and thank
you for what you do
people how can people find um find you
big love big love animal rescue we're on
instagram at big love animal rescue
we're on facebook
our website is biglabs animalrescue.org
and there's always to donate through
through the website um and on instagram
um
if a dog can tell if a person
you know it's funny when you when you're
like you see women you know that have
dogs
and if you go over and the dog likes you
the woman immediately says oh wow she
doesn't like anybody
and or or if the dog doesn't like
somebody they're pretty good judge
that's also a judging factor right
somebody that we know that the dog
did not like the guy and barked at the
guy
and the guy wasn't very nice to the dog
but the girl was all about the dog
and you know he probably read the energy
he read that the guy
didn't have crazy yeah he's like i don't
like that guy
you have to really you know and just be
very chill and
and and the dogs can sense that what
about beauty and the beast you think
people will marry dogs in the future
like with
they'll have those jimi hendrix jackets
on walk down the eye open big parties
that's awesome it's a good it's a good
way to get a date you guys if you want
to just like have a little puppy around
or a little dog cute little dog
a lot of women magnet there
what makes somebody a crazy dog because
i don't think you're a crazy dog person
i've i've seen
and dealt with some myself
what what what have you seen someone do
that you said this person is a crazy
crazy dog or crazy cat person yeah well
it's kind of
circles back to what you were saying
earlier when you were telling your story
about
um you know not wanting people near you
i think there are some people that
are don't relate to humans and they get
so much unconditional love from animals
and it fills them
where they just want so many of them
because they're not a good people person
you know did you know that
i didn't i would have never put that
together i just thought they were crazy
but i get it
crazy because so so perfect sense if
somebody
is living alone in riverside alleged
and they got you know great gardens over
there
in fontana and they're lonely and
they're all alone
or whatever and they get a stray and
this cat is kissing and then
and then there's another one and there
it fills their life
and they actually don't even might not
even have the money for the animal and
they kind of don't care
they're just like i love this feeling
and i'm gonna just throw food at it i
don't have money and they're everybody's
making kittens and puppies but they just
they they need that feeling because they
can't get it from humans so that is what
i've noticed
that makes a lot of sense a lot explains
a lot
in 2003 i bought uh about
i bought a chihuahua riverside before i
knew about rescue chico he just passed
17 16. and then i went and did shark boy
and lava girl i bought
mayan found trixie his old lady and then
when we were living up in pebble beach
they had a
a baby and his name was monty
and he was born he was at the vet and
then anne said
you gotta go pick up monty at the vet
and pay for the caesarean
i wrote a check for a dog caesarean
unreal right that's so great
and i thought i'm out of the [ __ ]
hood now
i saw a picture of uh you put a sweater
on one of the chihuahuas
yeah i think it was a nice
not only that we thought fashion show
but then also the uh
the sweaters and all that stuff with it
you know yeah i i
you know i would say i'm a reluctant
rescuer i
appreciate um
and i know they appreciate like they say
somebody you know they know
what when you rescued them because when
you see them behind
a cage or the fence and
if anybody listen i would say to anybody
that's listening like if you got
if you got 15 minutes go to youtube and
look up
what would you look up uh dog getting
forgot dog getting
adopted from a rescue well i you can go
to my youtube channel which is big love
animal rescue and you can see
the um animals that i've saved from the
shelters you can see
i just have my latest video i crawled
into a
sewer and pulled out six puppies so i
like you know do these extreme rescues
not always but uh you can you can see
dogs and animals
and cats getting getting rescued and and
people really like giving them a second
chance yeah
i saw that thing it's a kind of you know
the small tunnel you go in there and
and yeah yeah yeah what do you got no so
it like what would you say what would
you what would your
like for being on the show what was your
big note to be to end on to tell people
oh tomorrow i think i would say like
first of all if you're
if you're gonna get a dog it is a life
commitment so you better think about
if you have the finances for it and you
have the time for it because you have to
remember
you have friends you have a whole family
you have a whole life that
animal you are its whole life so when
you're gone you're working all day you
come home it's waiting for you
right so you it the animal has to have a
full life too and if you can't give it
give that dog a good life or that cat
then don't get an animal when
the late merle haggard who was a
wonderful musician
legend he was performing at the saban
and on wilshire
and i'd seen a documentary on the road
about him and he had a hard life
and then i said i want to go see him so
his tour manager said
you know merle's on the bus so we go in
there smells like weeds
smells like weed all right and then
merle has a george dickel
uh whiskey and they're all drinking from
the bottle no glass he says we're
country folk we don't
believe in glasses so i'll drink the
bottom and it wasn't until i almost left
that
on merle's right hip was a chihuahua
that was
right in there with them and the wife
said oh the dog doesn't leave the side
like oh it was like you couldn't even
see it like just right there so sweet
awesome yeah so thanks for alex because
he's uh
he's a great dog isn't he oh he's
awesome
i was messing with him today he can hold
his breath underwater two minutes
listen to that and go on youtube and go
to big love rescue and uh
donate and uh also be considerate if you
look
about having a pedal and also and also
when the shelters open up again go
volunteer
or volunteer for a rescue group like get
involved just
see how you can participate and help us
out because we can't do it alone
like you brian yeah all right thank you
you